what are you thinking when you look at
Harrison Ford oh I I was thinking the
same as I think now when I look at
Harrison Ford which is there as a
beautiful man in every way you know
we're physically beautiful but also
beautiful inside and I'm I've got the
great honor now of working with him
again all these many years later I mean
so and in 1923 which we'll talk about
you know
of course
is he still so hot yeah yeah well I mean
I mean he's married I don't mean it that
way no appropriately speaking I mean
Harrison Ford yeah he is he is
um he is
okay The Madness of King George
I loved this film
so much as Rupert Everett okay dirty
detail behind the scenes fly on the wall
moment what's going on oh well you know
I love the costumes on that on that film
you know I love a costume and there you
had dresses that were sort of you know
they didn't stick out in front they
stuck out stuck out sideways like this
and you and and we were shooting in real
palaces and you realize the reason all
the doorways were incredibly wide and
also the chairs were incredibly wide was
because they were literally built the
house to incorporate the costumes the
clothes that people were wearing because
you couldn't go in so you otherwise you
you'd have to sort of go in like this
you know through a door like this and
then out again because they're literally
this ride oh my God but the funny thing
the funny thing I've worn these two of
these kind of poop things quite often
and the funny thing about the hoop is
you have to be very careful when you sit
down because sometimes you've got this
round thing like this right and if you
if you if you're not careful you sit
down and the whole thing goes straight
up like that
[Laughter]
so when you sit down everybody if you're
wearing a hoop skirt you know hold it
down as you sit down like that okay
Gosford Park you were Oxford nominated
um a beautiful beautiful film yeah
it was great
terrible wig
the ugliest hair but anyway so in
service of the character what can you do
well calendar girls which is also
another incredible movie
with the lovely Julie Walters yeah
Julie Walters is the kind of actress who
is just naturally funny I'm not
naturally funny I you know
um I I just don't have that thing that
certainly needs a degree but okay but
Julie Walters is naturally funny and she
just she just she just says a line
perfectly straight and it's funny and I
don't know why but she's brilliant do
you ever spend time around people
sometimes where certain people you know
don't bring something out me and other
people do I don't know what they bring
it out yeah
you turn into Nicholson yeah yeah and
then some people don't do that but I
love people that bring out a certain
part of my own humor version of you that
Jack Nicholson version
I'm gonna give you a little bit of Jack
Nicholson back what do you think about
that I think I like it yeah
[Applause]
you're winning
why where do I start really
um love the corgis the corgis were great
they're great little dogs I'm a corgi
yeah
I am you have the character for Corgi oh
thank you which is very like very
curious very fun very oh into everything
you are a corgi and you've got the
corgi-colored hair
I can die happily now thank you they've
become very fashionable dogs corgis
apparently because people finally
recognize what sort of cute little dogs
they are yeah
stay
come on come on
[Applause]
[Music]